Paris climate agreement finally gets
signed as we ask for other countries go
to their Parliament's Congress's and
take steps that are at least in the
short term potentially against their
economic best interests when one of the
two candidates for president running
profits now has said that he would ban
in that agreement how do you have that
conversation with another country it's
harder when you have a candidate running
for president who obviously is espousing
a different point of view it makes it
harder it creates a delay in some
countries people will say well let's
wait and see what the outcome of the
election is before we make a decision
fortunately most countries have leaders
who actually understand science and so
the fact is that we now already this
year have so many countries that have
signed up to the agreement there were
over the 55 countries and we're over the
fifty five percent of emissions
represented by those countries so this
agreement is going to come into force in
the beginning of november and that is a
monumental accomplishment it's huge
because everybody in the marketplace now
understands with clarity that this
agreement is going to be in force and
that means that is the path the world is
setting out on for the future production
of energy for our nation for our all of
our nations which will it's already
creating a revolution in terms of energy
production i met this morning with a
group of energy CEOs here in the in the
valley all of whom are engaged in
putting out renewable sustainable
alternative energy particular solar was
represented among others wind was
represented and they were trying to do
this in africa they're trying to do
distributive power and get it out into
communities that have no electricity
which is critical by the way to really
dealing with the crisis of terrorism I
mean if you've got to deal with poverty
you've got to deal with these young
people who have no future if you don't
have electricity in a country it's hard
to provide jobs hard to be a kind of you
know educate people and so forth so
people here in America need to see the
connection
of what we choose to do in terms of
energy or other kinds of things with
respect to the opportunities that are
available to people in other countries
but in terms of energy policy now the
fact is it is in it is absolutely
uncontested by any reasonable standard
of accounting that if you make a choice
for alternative renewable energy it is
not in fact more expensive than the long
run because if you're doing coal-fired
power plant for instance which
California doesn't do now but in the
East it's still an issue your costs are
going to be much greater in the long run
because you're going to have health
concerns you're going to have co2
emission acidification of the ocean
you're going to have problems with the
quality of air you're going to have
environmentally induced asthma for kids
which costs billions every year I mean
there are all kinds of costs to fossil
fuel-burning that do not get accounted
for in the context of normal business
accounting and it doesn't make sense so
when they tell you well wow we got to do
coke it's Cole's only three cents a
kilowatt hours now true Cole ultimately
is much more expensive than the now
three cents of solar by the way through
there are contracts for solar being left
for about two point nine nine cents or
three cents a kilowatt hour so as the
accounting changes the entire
marketplace is going to change and last
year we had a record 358 billion dollars
that invested in energy in the energy
sector new energy alternative energy
renewable energy gas gasification and so
forth so we're on a different course
here and I'm very confident that we've
created a construct which could help
solve the problem if people continue
down that path if they don't were in
trouble